[Music]
another hero of mine was Bill Cosby now
I know even by bringing up Bill Cosby
it's very sad state when your childhood
hero becomes the biggest serial rapist
of all time but putting upside rape
first putting is like that whole thing
per second everything maybe we can we'll
find out but to me
Cosby did something incredible he put on
the black family that I think you wanted
to see right that even though you're
acknowledging that just what gets the
television isn't supposedly the magic
answered all this but he enabled black
people and white people also to see a
middle-class family he was a obstetrics
nor a gynecologist his wife was a lawyer
they were all successful they had the
same struggles that everybody else had
it didn't end well for Cosby but do you
credit him with doing some good they're
looking back yes and what happened was
the Liberals or the main people who got
at him because of what he stood up and
said to this black audience he said
blacks need to take care of education
instead of going out and buying Jordans
and black women need to stop having a
bunch of children that they can't take
care of that was the end how dare you
say something about the sacred cow in
the black community black woman when I
was a child you could get into a fight
with someone just because they said your
mama they don't have to say anything
about your mother but just start the
sentence right just your mama but
there's no such thing as yo daddy if
someone had said something about my dad
I would have like you know him I ought
to be more surprised that they said
something about this guy I've never seen
it your daddy fight yeah so Bill Cosby
put in front of America like you said
the black people were able to look at a
fully functional family because in the
80s we didn't have it the crack had
started to destroy the black family
after the whole Great Society mm-hmm you
had this man showing civility and
manhood and being a man in this house
and most of us didn't see it and you
also had white people saying well maybe
all the black people aren't like what
we're seeing on the news because here's
a different set cuz a lot of white
people's only interaction with black is
either through music or through
television that's it so why not have
this positive view well I also remember
when I was
and The Cosby Show was on I remember
black people turning against The Cosby
Show saying well ain't real that ain't
real you want to keep it real so what
they started to do was give black people
what they asked for real disfunction
Love & Hip Hop housewives well the women
were never wives they were just women
that got knocked up yeah
but drink throwing in each other's faces
and fighting in the middle of the
streets and WorldStarHipHop now that's
the black family how do you separate
them the artists from the art this is a
bit of a side bar here but Cosby I'm
with you on all that I love that show I
mean I he was my hero from when I was
five years old I went into stand-up when
I saw his first special I thought it was
the greatest thing ever so he's doing
what you argue is a great thing and now
I guess it is a transition to the right
part he was also doing something pretty
horrible to the black family because he
was part of a black family at the same
time and his son struggled with drugs
and and all that stuff and was killed I
think maybe in a drug deal I'm not was
it a drug deal I can't remember I don't
know he was shot and was that um but
this is a little bit of a sidebar but
separating the art from the artist is
tough right because he did so much good
and then at the same time was doing
something horrible
well liberals I have no problem doing it
with Roman Polanski yeah they celebrated
him and he ripped it he raped and
drugged a thirteen-year-old what Bill
Cosby is alleged to do my thoughts on it
usually makes people upset because I say
this if you are a woman and you knew he
was doing this to you and there's
generations of these women you had an
ethical and a moral responsibility to
stop the man before he did it for 20
more years yeah but a lot of them didn't
know I mean he was bringing back young
actresses who didn't they would have a
drink and then real you know assuming
all this stuff is true and again it's
all right we don't have to go too far
that you know like neither one of us are
lawyers privy to every bit of it right I
just want people if you're going through
I look for the person to stand up and
say no more I don't want it to happen in
anyone else because you do understand
that the reason why a lot of these
rapists molesters get away with what
they're doing is because the people who
had happened to feel sheltered and they
feel like they can't go out and speak so
they don't or they don't want to
especially like what happened on Penn
State those are men and we're not as
outraged about Penn State as we are
about the
actresses who were trying to get
something from Bill Cosby those kids
were just children but because they were
males we don't care about them we don't
care about all the males in jails to
this day we make jokes about them going
to jail and getting raped getting
violated we would never make this joke
just like when Sharon Osbourne got on
television and made the joke about the
man who got his penis cut off and thrown
inside of the food processor she thought
it was hilarious have you ever seen
anyone make a joke about a mutilated
woman on national television and
continue to keep that job the only
person who I can ever think of making a
joke about female genital mutilation
actually is Linda Sarsour who is thought
of as a hero of the left you know she's
the woman that led the the women's March
and all that and she's mocking ayaan
Hirsi Ali who literally underwent female
genital mutilation so that does show you
a little of the perverseness of this
whole situation but as a man and
especially as a white man like you can't
make any joke like as a comedian it's
funny because you're like well what can
I say that won't get me in trouble as a
black man I get on stage and say
anything has a black woman you have your
limitless you know it's it's funny I
don't know that I've even said this
publicly I used to say this in stand-up
but I would know when I was really in
the thick of stand-up for many years in
New York that if I could get if there
was a to know mostly usually the
audience was pretty diverse ethnically
but if there was a table of black people
if I could get them to laugh everyone
else would laugh and if I said anything
remotely politically incorrect
you could feel white people kind of
looking like that if they 11 okay so I
did consciously I would do that and I
also found that in general black
audiences are great because there's a
realness there and a rawness there and
what if they don't you know I remember I
was on stage once telling some stupid
joke like some joke about the
Transformers or something and some girl
a black girl up front goes you corny she
said you call it and from that boy boy
they change what I was doing because I
was like wait a minute my just telling
corny jokes up here and so but that even
goes to the guilt thing that white
people are sitting there backwards
laughter okay this funny like man we're
in a weird spot well when I did comedy I
did it two for three years and it was
just some of the hardest thing to do
because it's real work yeah as you have
to work for them and I said that's the
same thing that you said when I was
dealing with white audiences it
better for me because what they would
encourage you to because they were
already paid so if you bombed or you'll
get the next one but the black people
came in ready to boo you had to convince
them to laugh yeah so it almost became
contentious but I was like you I was
like if there's a black table I'm going
to make them laugh because if they laugh
everyone else will laugh but if I make
everyone else laugh and they don't
they're gonna shut it down yeah
they're gonna get me off of this stage
and it's a strange dynamic but again
goes back to how the Liberals are
telling blacks to just be disruptive
look at what's going on throughout the
United States there are more people
black women black people who are making
petitions you can look online to ban me
from the internet yeah
then there are petitions to ban the
murder that's going on in Chicago you
don't see black women upset with that
but you'll see black women upset what
what are some celebrity dating of a non
black woman this will be front-page news
but these murders that are happening
every weekend in one small area is as
normal it's not it's not march worthy
it's not protest worthy it's not we can
shut this down worthy no we can deal
with these black kids killing each other
as long as no cop comes and does it
right right so that so I see this all
the time you'll see people on say Fox
News and they'll talk about what's going
on with the cops and then like Hannity
will say well but nobody's talking about
what's happening in Chicago and you know
thousands of people have been shot in
Chicago over the last couple years
hundreds have been killed I mean it's
it's crazy it has a Democratic mayor by
the way it was most of these cities with
these inner city problems our democratic
mayors and then there were people out of
the street blaming Trump who wasn't even
president at the time it's gone your
mayors Democrats the president's
Democrat okay but do you think that's a
little bit of a shell game because I
don't know that the Republicans have
done I I do consider yourself a
Republican what do you consider is that
probably more of a libertarian but they
put me on the Republican side I voted
for Trump I will vote my conscious I'm
not one of those people that will go
into there and then I'm all liberal on
all conservatives I don't think that
anyone should do that number one and
number two we don't teach American
citizens that their local elections
matter more than the presidential
election but that's the only time
they'll come out during the presidential
election that's the only time
when they're being told to care well
where are all these liberals trying to
bust them to vote for their mayor to
vote for their tax commissioner to vote
for all of these other things the people
in Ferguson complained about the police
force was so white yet they could have
raised their kids to grow up to want to
apply the white people were like we took
who applied though those people were
told that they don't want to grow up to
be cops that they hate cops so this
whole neighborhood of black people
didn't decide to raise their children up
to say well if we don't want to be
policed by whites why don't you go and
apply for the job nope it's better for
you to be some kind of dance or a rapper
cuz I don't get us out quick most of
what black society because there's no
fathers in the home you spoke earlier
about how it's how things are being
taught to the children who are Chinese
or Indian well the difference is when
you have a father a father will teach
you the slow and steady route instead of
the get-rich-quick scheme scheme women
are the ones who do this thing called
sugar baby women are the ones who are
online and well they have booking
information on there
IG but the booking is actually I got
enough money right so women are doing
this you don't see many men able to get
up there and be like hey look at me if
you want it so we can't do that so we
kind of have to work yeah but pretty
woman can get way more than a pretty man
can get that being said as a father when
you have one in the house he's not gonna
teach his kids get-rich-quick schemes
take that man out all you have is a
person who's living off of the
government whose mere existence becomes
and I said it's about black women people
got mad when I said I said at their
child's birth they typically get paid
and then at their child's death they get
paid you understand there's a young girl
who got hit by a train I don't know if
you saw the story she was modeling she
got hit by train while she was modeling
for some reason the 20 year the 19 year
old girl was on the train tracks
modeling and they talked about how
intelligent she was and she had a
volleyball scholarship but she decided
to forego the volleyball scholarship to
chase her dream of modeling now I'm not
a great eye for talent but she was not
modeled material she wasn't she could do
urban modeling which everybody knows
that's completely different that's no
face back shot but she was on this train
she got hit doing
job and when she got hit they said it's
a shame she just found out she was four
weeks pregnant so let me get this
straight she forgot she forego college
because she felt that it was get in the
way of her modeling career but being a
parent is okay I can have a kid and
still model and that's the logic that's
being taught by the Liberals to the
blacks that being irresponsible is okay
now when she died
this woman claimed it well they threw
out that her boyfriend was her fiancee
when we had no evidence of that no ring
no nothing but what were they looking
for GoFundMe so every time a black kid
like the one in knew the one in Chicago
who got shot seven times across the test
Tyshawn Lee execution-style mom gets
GoFundMe money she goes and buys a car
and goes on vacation in Vegas because
she knows she can do it again she could
have another kid and then now I can put
another guy on child support ruin his
life and get money from the state and
continue to live in this same poor
environment but I'm used to it
because they've been generations of
poverty so poverty doesn't affect us
used to it so what do you make of the
people I would argue someone like an al
Sharpton who have become you probably
answered it already with the slight Matt
of a head who have become really sort of
professional agitators in this but for
all of the activism that he has done for
these years and for on behalf of the
Democrats things have only gotten worse
so what does that tell you well he's
gotten richer and by the way I'm pretty
sure he doesn't pay his taxes but that's
all I think that's right well the thing
is they've created victims out of black
people saw a video today before I came
here black woman and it started become
worldwide now black lives matter I have
a friend he does music Pogo I don't know
if you've ever heard of it he's moving
music lives in Perth Australia and he
says black lives matters here and it
doesn't even make any sense
it's like black people all over seeing
what American blacks are doing he giving
away with it so this story this woman is
at this eating dinner and her children
are beating this little white kid so
finally the father cuz of course it's
just a woman and her kids no man mm-hmm
but this white guy and his family were
watching their kid get beat by her kid
so he's like why would
you stop your kid so he gets animated
she gets animated she's cursing him out
telling me he doesn't tell her what to
do the next thing you know she starts
yelling is it because I'm black
it's because I'm black and the people in
the comment sections like yeah I've
races white mounds like he would have
done that if anybody was beating his kid
yeah the thing you should ask the parent
cuz you can't beat the kid but you can't
ask the parent why are you allowing this
why is this okay and yet people skip the
fact that this man was taking up for his
children
it was his races because he's speaking
to that woman and becoming animated and
that's what Jesse Jackson and Al
Sharpton is doing they're creating
victim victimhood victimology to where
if you don't get your way then you're a
victim you're only saying it's because
I'm black you can get horrible service
from a black waitress but you can't say
anything about it like the other black
waitress you know how many of these and
I have so much going through my mom but
you know I'm many of these situations
that's happened over the past year and a
half where was these black people who
were being mistreated by white people
and you found out they were hoaxes they
were being placed on Donald Trump look
at what Donald Trump's election is doing
this woman was written a tip we don't
tip blacks come to find out she wrote
that herself
the other one said thanks thanks [ __ ]
no thanks [ __ ] we won't be leaving a
tip that was written down the other
white stickers in the bathroom all made
up there was a black woman who actually
cut herself and set herself on fire and
it and was trying to make white people
look bad look at what happened with the
Duke Lacrosse case al Sharpton was there
where was he when we found out it was a
lie
it's one of their to one a brown yeah
they still bring her up knowing it was a
lie yeah where were those liberals after
they realized where was our Sharpton
nowhere to be found cuz he wants you to
be a professional victim he's an
ambulance chaser he's only telling black
people to feel bad and think everything
is racist he's never telling them to
build their home if he really cared
about blacks why wouldn't he just say
well instead of complaining build room
at the Masters won't let you in they
have golf courses in places you can
build golf courses all over the place we
have all these well-off black people and
actors and whatever they can build their
own because right now we want to get
Awards on TBS and and NBC and whatever
while we still have
entertainment TV but if there was a
white entertainment TV how far would
that go if there was a white NBF right
now why people say well we can't get in
the NBA's listeners make our own we'd
still call that racist yet we have a
WNBA where women are allowed to go and
play and keep me and out right
white NBA that sounds terrible that's a
lot of mid-range jump shot that's it no
it will be fun ritalin sounds yeah
nobody I mean from my own future maybe
it would be nice but you know it doesn't
sound it being a bTW and be able to
occasional Brown yeah more dunks in the
WNBA there's a couple of girls that can
dunk now when you how hard is it to wake
people up to this stuff because people
know this I've mentioned a couple times
on the show when I had Larry elder on
the first time who says a lot of the
same things that you're saying and he's
really I think he's an incredibly good
interviewing and you know lays out
numbers doesn't just make [ __ ] up he
lays out numbers when I had him on the
first time I definitely had not come
around on a lot of this stuff that I now
obviously agree with you on and and he
really challenged me on I said there's
systemic racism and he and then he
turned it on me I didn't expect him to
and it was not a particularly good
moment for me but we didn't edit it out
because I wanted my audience to see that
I don't have all the answers
subsequently Larry's been back on the
show we're now friends and I think we've
I credit him for a lot of my awakening
so when you're doing this work this is
work what you're doing when you're doing
this how hard is it to deal with members
of the black community who maybe don't
want you to expose that stuff that you
said before you know it's like we got it
may be true but we got to keep it quiet
I've gotten death threats I continue to
get death threats they put out my
address they put up my phone number you
have people dedicated right now someone
says we're gonna make sure he's broke
gonna make sure they take away his house
and his car and we're gonna have him
back in the hood where he deserves to be
all because of my opinion now you have
to understand my own mom thought that
what I was doing was wrong because she
said well you shouldn't be airing black
people's dirty laundry and you hear that
a lot in the black community that it's
our dirty laundry you shouldn't be
airing it as if no one knew that the
poverty existed no one knew that the
murder existed like the news will talk
about the murder in Chicago but if I
take one of those clips and talk about
this
systemic part of that murder well then
I'm a [ __ ] I get called these names that
blacks know that White's used to degrade
blacks but blacks want to be in position
to do that a lot of people are you're
getting this from people on the left
right oh these people they think of
themselves as liberals or leftist and
they're the ones sling in this horrible
[ __ ] at you which I see they do with
Larry and they've done with my friend
Maajid Nawaz who's Muslim trying to
reform Islam to bring it into the
current century and they who gives him
[ __ ] that's so-called tolerant left
they're supposed to be tolerant enough
to have a discussion and they don't even
understand how to have a discussion
it's a name-calling session it is a
shaming tactic and that's what a lot of
blacks will do to black people they will
shame you they will you worried about
being called a sellout you worried about
being called a [ __ ] you're worried about
being called a race traitor you're
worried about so much of these things
because they will ruin your career that
you can't go the company the company
lines you have to tow that party line
and that party line is blacks are
perpetual victims they're always a
victim no matter what happened we are
victims of it even when we kill
ourselves we're a victim of society
wanted us to do it and we just couldn't
not do it even though they claim now
they're dropping guns off in these
neighborhoods so the black people aren't
smart enough not to shoot each other
with the guns or see them laying in
street they gotta shoot each other they
gave us drugs well we weren't smart
enough not to take them at a certain
point in time responsibility needs to be
taught and because I'm teaching
responsibility I become an enemy to a
whole lot of people who are making money
or living comfortably yeah it's a threat
to them you know the phrase the soft
bigotry of low expectations yeah which
was a phrase that people credit to Bill
Maher but it was actually originally
from George W Bush and that's what's
happening here it's the soft bigotry of
low expectations it's like when you say
well if we draw a cartoon of a certain
thing these people are obviously savages
so they're gonna kill us and you're
dealing with the same thing on your
community it's that these the soft
bigotry of these liberals is keeping
people that are tall you've said here
for the entire time there is you've
basically made one theme personal
responsibility that's it
and that's what America is supposed to
be about well that's where we change
changing with this whole idea of
feminism feminism is allowing these
women to steal ask you to be chivalrous
and pay for dates and stuff like that
they're asking you not to hit a woman
but she can level off and hit you
because you're bigger than her goes back
to the whole animal in the cage thing as
a black person I can call you all kinds
of names right now and it would never
stop me from getting on any other show
I'd call y'all kind of crackers whitey
whatever if you say one thing and
respond back in current Tommy Lehren was
having that problem they could say
whatever they wanted to to her call her
O'Connor white [ __ ] if she responds
to any black woman says well you're a
black [ __ ] it's just in response she's
immediately racist so what you've done
is tongue-tie this person so that they
can't respond back to you and it made
you more aggressive it's basically like
the I don't know if you remember it was
always the kid that had a bigger brother
because your big brother would always
take up for me put his big brother in
position to have to yeah cuz he had Big
Brother behind him same thing with a lot
of people with guns if they have a gun
on them they become a tough guy a lot of
these women are becoming tougher not
easier to deal with because you have so
many people backing them up the guy on
the bus he was spit on and hit in the
back of the head while driving the bus
he pulls over and he hits the woman
everybody jumped up to her defense and
said that's a female yeah so it was okay
for this female to hit the man driving
this bus full of people he could have
crashed but he should take it because
he's a man right now I say something you
date men died about 10 to 15 years
earlier than women life expectation if
this was reversed there would be all
types of commercial saying we got it but
he's what is life expectancy up right
now you have a big strong football
players who when they get old guess what
they will probably suffer from prostate
cancer yeah guess what they won't suffer
from breast cancer but in October
they're walking around decked out in
pink but in November they don't have on
blue this is a society that we're
pushing that males do not matter they're
just an ATM machine they're a source of
income and whenever white people get a
cold is because black people had the flu
so that means that if it's starting to
hurt your community its devastated ours
blacks people are America's canary in
the coalmine if you see it happening to
us it's coming to you
you
[Music]